et pour ce club spécial avec nous
Benjamin Morel bonjour Benjamin merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous
constitutionnalistes et auteurs de ce
livre la France en miettes régionalise
l'autre séparatisme s'est aux éditions
du Cerf et Frédéric Berry est avec nous
bonjour merci d'être là président de la
collectivité européenne d'Alsace Alex
nous a rejoint et si vous êtes là
messieurs c'est parce qu'on va faire un
grand débat dans ce club autour de cette
question le régionalisme est-il une
menace pour l'unité de la République
c'est c'est la thèse de votre livre
Benjamin on va en parler exactement
certains et on vend débattre avec
Frédéric Berry évidemment mais d'abord
Alex pour y voir claire un point il y a
plusieurs collectivités dans le pays qui
ont un statut particulier oui il y en a
beaucoup alors d'abord on va aller en
métropole ou certaines collectivités ont
un statut particulier on va voir et bien
les cas de Paris Lyon de l'Alsace et de
la Corse d'abord la ville de Paris à
cette particularité d'avoir à la fois
les compétences d'une commune et d'un
département la métropole de Lyon depuis
quelques années regroupe les compétences
du département du Rhône et de l'aire
urbaine de Lyon et puis il y a la
connectivité européenne d'Alsace
récemment créée qui fonctionne comme un
département mais avec des compétences
supplémentaires relatives à la
coopération transfrontalière la
promotion du bilinguisme ou encore la
politique touristique et puis la
collectivité de Corse à un statut unique
avec un exécutif une assemblée des
compétences élargies sur l'éducation le
développement économique les transports
le logement ou encore l'environnement et
Alexandre outre-mer les collectivités
ont tout un statut particulier et oui là
on est vraiment sur des statuts sur
mesure pour chaque territoire mais on
peut distinguer deux types de
collectivités d'outre-mer d'abord ce
qu'on appelle les régions et
départements d'outre-mer c'est à dire
des collectivités qui ont à la fois les
compétences de d'une région et d'un
département c'est le cas de la
Guadeloupe de la Réunion et de Mayotte
la Martinique et la Guyane font aussi
partie de ces de cette catégorie mais on
le statue de collectivité unique et puis
ensuite vous avez des collectivités
d'outre-mer plus autonomes il s'agit des
îles Wallis-et-Futuna
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon
Saint-Barthélémy Saint-Martin et la
française alors chaque territoire a
quand même des statues et une autonomie
différent et puis autre cas de figure la
Nouvelle-Calédonie qui est bien est
engagée dans un processus de
décolonisation régie par l'Accord de
Nouméa de 1988 à cet accord il prévoyait
et bien un transfert de compétences
importantes de l'État vers les nouvelles
Calédonie et puis une série de
référendum d'autodétermination qui se
sont seuls dès ces dernières années par
un maintien dans la République française
il faut noter aussi que les institutions
de Nouvelle-Calédonie partagent la
souveraineté avec l'État ça c'est une
particularité il y a aussi une
citoyenneté néocalédonienne propre et
l'État reste seulement compétent dans le
domaine régalien merci Alex pour ce
point on va y aller directement
messieurs est-ce que ces statues
particuliers se sont une richesse ou une
menace pour l'unité de la République
française alors si vous regardez tous
les exemples européens moi ce que je
fais un petit peu en tant comparatiste
et bien vous regardez que les problèmes
en termes de régionalisme on va revenir
peut-être sur ce que c'est à dire que si
j'ai pas de dire la région est en
elle-même le problème ni d'ailleurs les
identités régionales encore moins ce
qu'on pourrait appeler les petites
patries mais le régionalisme politique
celui qui vise à un séparatisme
vis-à-vis de la nation ils s'enrichit
d'une chose en réalité c'est pas la
décentralisation prenez l'Allemagne vous
avez un pays très décentralisé mais de
manière symétrique tous les Länders ont
les mêmes compétences et ont un statut à
peu près particulier à peu près égale
vous pouvez avoir des variations dans
les noms vous avez des vous avez des
l'Ender qui vont avoir des appellations
particulières mais grosso modo le statut
est le même ce qui pose problème à
l'étranger c'est ce qu'on appelle la
décentralisation asymétrique c'est à
dire quand vous avez un jeu qui va être
un jeu de différenciation justement des
statuts avec un élément si j'ai une
identité plus affirmée j'ai le droit à
un statut qui est un statut de plus
d'autonomie alors a priori entre gérer
une compétence publique et avoir une
identité affirmée il n'y a pas de lien
direct entre une compétence santé et une
identité priori on pourrait se dire que
le lien est pas direct mais malgré tout
si je veux affirmer mon identité je veux
avoir plus de compétences et donc ce
faisant c'est ce c'est cet élément qui
va entraîner un qui fait qui est en
effet désagrégation à la fois à travers
une forme de concurrence interne entre
les parties et ensuite entre des
concurrences internes entre les régions
et il y a un risque de désagrégation si
vous regardez aujourd'hui ce qui se
passe les Corses disent nous on veut un
statut à la néocalédonienne et je pense
que Frédéric Biry nous dira que le
statut Corse est très enviable donc
c'est ce jeu entre guillemets de course
les uns avec les autres qui à terme
devient dangereux
dans les années 68 69 il disait la
nation française est consolidée et
aujourd'hui on doit s'appuyer sur la
richesse et la diversité des
spécificités
territoriales pour construire une
décentralisation qui a qui a du sens et
aujourd'hui je crois pas qu'ils
problèmes pour moi de d'identité
aujourd'hui le combat que je mène pour
l'Alsace c'est un combat pour améliorer
l'efficacité de l'action publique pour
revitaliser la démocratie et je pense
que c'est à partir des réalités des
territoires quand il y a un sentiment
d'appartenance que nos concitoyens sont
prêts à se réinvestir et aujourd'hui on
voit bien la République est affaiblie si
on veut la renforcer je pense que c'est
par la proximité des territoires donc
pour vous c'est pas un enjeu identitaire
c'est une question d'efficacité alors
après politique d'efficacité de
politique c'est cela exactement et mais
le sentiment d'appartenance a un
territoire c'est ça qui peut amener les
gens à se dépasser à s'impliquer dans la
société dans la citoyenneté et c'est ça
qu'il faut qu'on réussisse à
reconstruire dans une société oui alors
le sentiment d'appartenance il est pas
du tout contenable bien au contraire
c'est à dire la logique de la Petite
Patrie telle qu'on l'entend
historiquement c'est grosso modo et bien
l'appartenance à un tissu politique
culturel local qui fait que tout d'un
coup vous avez envie de participer à
cette grande patrie qui est la nation
donc ça en soit c'est pas du tout
condamnable et la décentralisation
permet ça le problème en réalité c'est
que en singularisant les statuts je crée
une forme de concurrence identitaire et
ça on le voit très très bien à
l'étranger et avec cette concurrence
identitaire et bien j'ai une identité
qui de plus en plus devient antagoniste
et aujourd'hui en effet quand vous
parlez de Gaulle en effet de Gaulle à
une approche de la décentralisation qui
a une approche dirait relativement
classique il crée des régions où il veut
créer des régions ces régions ont les
mêmes compétences et même compositions
etc on est dans quelque chose de très
très classique le problème c'est
qu'actuellement on dérive justement vers
quelque chose de nouveau où vous avez
cette concurrence d'identité et vous
avez qui plus est on y reviendra
peut-être avec la Bretagne parce que la
collectivité européenne d'Alsace est
relativement exemplaire en la matière
mais avec un usage parfois très détourné
des symboles et aujourd'hui en effet à
si vous regardez un certain nombre
d'enquêtes la Corse par exemple et la
région d'Europe pour lesquelles on vote
le plus pour des parties régionalistes
ou séparatistes plus qu'en Catalogne
plus qu'en Écosse si vous prenez la
Bretagne le taux de Breton qui se dit
breton plus que français est passé en 30
ans de 15 à 40 %. donc on a des
mouvements de fond en Alsace on a des
sondages plus anciens mais on voit
également qu'il y a une forme de montée
à un moment si vous prenez les autres
pays d'Europe il y a un moment où ça
craque je parlais du taux de breton se
disant plus breton français c'est
exactement le même taux d'écossais qui
se disait écossais plus que britannique
au début des années 2000 avant qu'on
rentre justement dans ce phénomène de
surenchère donc oui là-dessus on n'est
pas immunisée on va parler de la
Bretagne dans quelques secondes mais
vous entendez ce que dit Benjamin
Frédéric Berry est-ce que ce que vous
dites à savoir que pour vous ce qui
prime c'est l'efficacité politique et
l'efficacité économique ça ne va pas
forcément dériver vers quelque chose de
plus identitaire en tout cas moi je le
ressens pas du tout comme ça en Alsace
en Alsace on est très attaché à la
nation française notre pays à la
République et d'ailleurs toutes les
décentralisations qu'on a mené en Alsace
à l'époque Adrien Zeller etc ont
toujours apporté une valeur ajoutée à
l'action publique nationale et c'est
comme ça qu'on inscrit aujourd'hui notre
démarche après incompatible d'être
attaché à la République et de vouloir se
singulariser et montrer son identité
je pense qu'au contraire c'est une
richesse c'est une richesse
supplémentaire pour la nation française
et dès lors qu'on reste attaché à la
République c'est vrai que chez nous on
est attaché à la République et on pense
d'ailleurs que aujourd'hui avec la
marque Alsace par contre par exemple on
apporte un plus à notre pays on
contribue à réduire le déficit de la
balance commerciale on est aujourd'hui
dans une territoire avec une singularité
à la fois transfrontalière et européenne
avec des 80 institutions internationales
à Strasbourg donc nous nous on a une
démarche à la fois porteuse de porteuse
de la France porteuse aussi de l'Europe
Benjamin est-ce que parce que le
sous-titre de votre livre c'est
régionalise l'autre séparatisme est-ce
que être attaché à sa région vouloir la
défendre ça empêche d'être attaché à la
République est-ce que c'est forcément un
séparatisme absolument pas et là encore
une fois il faut distinguer plusieurs
concepts d'abord il y a un régionalisme
qui est un outil de décentralisation de
démocratisation c'est celui que vous
évoquez et on peut se retrouver mais
fondamentalement le problème avec ça
c'est qu'aujourd'hui les statuts
particuliers la complexification des
compétences font que la plupart des
citoyens ont du mal à comprendre si je
suis électeur en Alsace comprendre que
la collectivité européenne c'est pas une
collectivité à statut particulier mais
un département incompétence particulière
qui dispose de certaines compétences de
la région bref l'enjeu identitaire
devient saillant également parce que en
matière de décentralisation à moins
d'avoir fait un master de récent c'est
compliqué ensuite vous avez je dirais
une fin un Master 2 en Droit des
collectivités territoriales très récent
parce que ça change tous les trois ans
de l'autre côté et bien ce qu'on va
appeler les petites patries justement ce
sont en réalité des identités locales
qui vont être complémentaires de la
grande prenez les différentes langues
régionales etc la plupart du temps vous
avez un taux d'interpénie
d'interpénétration très fort avec les
langues locales prenez par exemple ce
qu'on pourrait appeler l'Alsacien mais
en réalité au sud de l'Alsace on va
parler plutôt je parle sous votre
contrôle mais un moyen allemand au nord
on va plutôt parler du français etc donc
on a en fait toute une gradation de
langues dans lequel le français
l'allemand vont être plus ou moins
pénétrant etc ça c'est évidemment
quelque chose qu'il faut sauver le
problème c'est quand vous dites bah
voilà ça c'est la longue régionale ça il
va falloir purger tous les apports du
français et on va reconstruire une
histoire on va l'idéaliser pour faire un
ennemi c'est la France ça c'est une
démarche idéologique cette démarche
idéologique elle est portée elle a été
portée historiquement par certains
groupes dans toutes les régions
françaises le problème aujourd'hui c'est
que pour tout un tas de raisons parce
que les vieilles générations qui étaient
porteuses de ces cultures parce que
également les collectivités qui avons
voulu se légitimer et donc ont été
chercher ce logiciel parce que c'était
celui qui était le plus facile le plus
pratique et le plus disponible et bien
on reprit et on communiqué là-dessus et
aujourd'hui en effet dans une partie de
la population et bien il y a cette idée
que l'Alsace c'est ça la Bretagne c'est
ça le Pays Basque c'est ça et là ça
devient dangereux parce qu'on est plus
dans la petite patrie on est dans une
démarche idéologique qui souvent a pas
grand chose à voir avec les cultures
originelles locales qu'au contraire on
est tous et là en effet un il y a danger
et il y a mort de culture alors deux
remarques par rapport à vos expressions
d'abord sur la simplification
institutionnelle nous ce qu'on défend
puisque vous évoquez les compétences de
la collectivité européenne d'Alsace
aujourd'hui on a rassemblé deux anciens
conseils départementaux du Haut-Rhin et
du bas donc on a des compétences
départementales plus quelques
compétences supplémentaires qui fait de
nous collectivités statut particulier de
fait pas de droit mais mais mais de fait
mais aujourd'hui ce qu'on attend nous
aujourd'hui c'est récupérer les
compétences de la région et ce qui fait
que pour nos concitoyens ce serait
simple une seule collectivité avec des
compétences croisées département région
qui permet d'appréhender la politique
publique à 360 à 360 degrés une
administration de moins moins d'élus
donc aujourd'hui on va dans le je pense
dans le sens de la simplification de
l'action publique donc ça c'est le
premier point je voulais évoquer le
deuxième par rapport aux langues nous on
a la fois l'Alsacien et l'allemand on
alsacien c'est un socle culturel
historique qui fait le lien entre nos
concitoyens et auxquels nous sommes
particulièrement attachés pour ça qu'on
a une petite très forte en la matière
mais c'est un attachement de lien et à
côté de cela on a l'enjeu du bilinguisme
avec l'allemand parce que là on a nous
nous l'espace de dynamique de notre
territoire c'est l'espace drainant donc
à la fois Suisse et le bas le bas de
Wurtenberg et c'est à cet échelle là
qu'on doit réfléchir aussi nos
politiques publiques et c'est comme ça
qu'on apporte une dynamique
supplémentaire à la France et c'est
comme ça que du coup on inscrit nous ces
enjeux à la fois alsaciens et bilingue
mais dans une démarche d'ouverture on
n'est pas dans une démarche de on se
referme sur nous-mêmes on est dans une
démarche de construction vers l'Europe
ou alors rapidement pour vous répondre
sur les deux points alors concernant les
collectivités à sais-tu particulier quoi
qu'on dise et quoi qu'on veuille et même
s'il y a des fusions entre les
différents niveaux ça ne simplifie pas
la plupart des de nos concitoyens
comprennent le schéma des collectivités
territoriales au niveau national quand
vous avez une forme d'homogénéité sinon
en fait la compréhension et le coût
d'entrée qui est déjà très grand en
matière décentralisation vous le savez
et bien ne se fait pas et donc ce
faisant vous avez un effet qu'un effet
déceptif un effet de retrait si vous
prenez les compétences des régions elles
n'ont fait que croître depuis les années
80 le taux d'abstention n'a fait
qu'augmenter tout bêtement parce que
c'est pas lisible c'est pas
compréhensible moi on peut se retrouver
sur l'idée que par exemple il faudrait
fusionner au niveau national région et
départements avec une collectivité
intermédiaire unique sur tout le
territoire dont l'Alsace pourrait être
parti parce que on va vite s'entendre
sur la loi neutre la loi notre a été une
absurdité et la fin de la région Alsace
et sa fusion dans le Grand Est les
régions exactement on a quand même un
monstre avec le Grand Est ce qui est
plus grand que la Belgique et la
Belgique
exactement est un pays fédéral la grande
Aquitaine c'est la taille de l’autriche
et c'est également un pays fédéral donc
si vous voulez on est face à des choses
qui de toute façon posent des problèmes
et la collectivité européenne d'Alsace
et je dirais la conséquence de ça et je
suis d'accord vous en avez pas l'origine
ensuite sur le fond fusionner c'est pas
forcément un apport démocratique
justement je disais là le grand est plus
que la taille de la Belgique et donc on
va fusionner des départements et on va
avoir de plus en plus des collectivités
intermédiaires qui sont quand même des
collectivités de grande taille alors
l'Alsace reste relativement à taille
humaine si vous fusionnez les
départements et la région bretonne là
vous arrivez avec une collectivité
extrêmement grande qui en fait est très
jacobine d'une certaine façon parce que
vous avez une seule et même collectivité
extrêmement éloignée aujourd'hui quand
vous prenez toutes les enquêtes il y a
deux demandes des Français lisibilité
les collectivités à statut particulier
n'y participent pas proximité voire
hyper proximité quand vous fusionnez
vers le haut ça n'y participe pas non
plus justement quand on parle de
démocratie nous nous avons mené une
action une consultation 160 000
personnes qui ont participé à cette
consultation 92% des anciens le retour
du d'Alsace à part entière donc on est
complètement aujourd'hui dans cette
logique démocratique et au regard
justement des différences entre les
territoires ça a du sens qui est des
territoires qui soient dans une forme de
différenciation qui n'est peut-être pas
valable partout parce que effectivement
les tailles font que les choses évoluées
et on voit bien aujourd'hui que ces
grandes régions notamment les régions
XXL celles qui ont rassemblé trois
anciennes régions on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui elles sont complètement
artificielles nos concitoyens ne peuvent
pas y adhérer on est dans des
républiques technocratiques là on
voudrait dans les républiques
démocratiques donc on a on a à mon sens
quelque chose à construire et on a
toujours été pionnier en Alsace de la
décentralisation on peut être
laboratoire d'une d'une organisation
nouvelle on va aller en Bretagne
Benjamin si vous le voulez bien parce
que vous me parlez de la Bretagne depuis
tout à l'heure on va y aller je vais
avoir besoin de VOUS Alex parce qu'en
Bretagne la ville de Vitré a décidé de
s'afficher en breton et les panneaux
d'entrée de vie affichent désormais avec
with règles voilà qui parle breton
beaucoup mieux que moi en complet en
complément
français dans le cadre d'une charte
signée le premier février manière de
mettre en avant les spécialités
régionales on regarde ce reportage de
Marion Delpech
aux portes de la Bretagne la ville de
Vitré en Ille-et-Vilaine ces 18000
habitants sont château ou flotte le
drapeau de la Bretagne et désormais ces
cinq nouveaux panneaux de signalisation
bilingue aux entrées et sorties de ville
une action menée dans le cadre de
l'adhésion à la charte pour le
développement de la longue bretonne
niveau 1 validé par les élus aujourd'hui
plus que jamais les régions ont besoin
de s'identifier nous voulons pouvoir
mener à bien des actions pour être plus
efficace plus lisible sur l'action
publique donc tous les discours que l'on
peut entendre aujourd'hui sur plus de
centralisation qui est le cas ne nous
convient absolument pas et c'est pour ça
qu'on y travaille dans une région à
forte identité comme celle de la
Bretagne nous pouvons faire des
propositions nous l'avons fait un
certain d'entre nous sont allés
rencontrer des parlementaires les
sénateurs travaillent sur ces questions
là et la Bretagne peut être un vrai
exemple à Vitré le Breton est promu à
l'école publique et priv auprès de 80
enfants à Rennes préfecture de la région
c'est une nouvelle filière bilingue pour
les primaires qui ouvrent tous les deux
ans et de plus en plus de lieux
culturels comme le musée de Bretagne
propose des audioges en breton et en
galop une initiative saluée par la
conseillère au langue de la ville élu du
parti Union démocratique bretonne située
à gauche de l'échiquier politique la
langue c'est aussi un facteur d'identité
quant à un citoyen lambda par le
français il sent que c'est sa langue et
que
c'était important et imaginez
l'importance ce que l'école donne à la
langue française donc on est tous
français ici mais on est aussi breton et
c'est à dire qu'il y a une partie de la
population qui qui voit dans cette
langue une langue qui périme et qui qui
mérite de d'être transmise encore pour
que les générations suivantes et cette
mémoire historique culturelle
et pourquoi pas politique décidé à
s'engager pour redonner à la Bretagne
des structures politiques économiques et
culturelles le Parti Breton demande le
transfert rapide de certaines
compétences à la région c'est indéniable
que beaucoup de sujets ont progressé sur
la réunification sur le rapport à la
langue aussi sur le logement sur toutes
les politiques en réalité que l'idée est
finalement qui ont aujourd'hui une
majorité de Bretons sont convaincus ou
de corps ou de basse ou de catalans ou
d'Alsaciens c'est qu'en fait des
politiques menées dans ces domaines-là
seront plus efficaces si elles sont
menées à partir du gouvernement
régionaux plutôt qu'à partir de Paris
comme c'est le cas actuellement une
question plus que jamais d'actualité
alors que les élus breton relancé ce
mois-ci le débat sur le rattachement de
la Loire-Atlantique à la Bretagne
Benjamin vous les comprenez ces élus
qu'on vient d'entendre et qui affiche la
culture bretonne mais qu'on affiche la
culture bretonne et même qu’on la sauve
ça m'apparaît tout à fait essentiel la
question c'est qu'est-ce qu'on sauve
quand vous voyez madame le CALENNEC la
mère de Vitré qui est très très fière de
présenter un panneau en breton devant sa
ville alors sans être extrêmement précis
sur l'histoire la Bretagne voir en
Bretagne on ne parle pas que Breton
historiquement on parle de langues à
l'ouest ou parler en effet le Breton
fait vous parler des différents versions
du breton du l'ENT etc qui sont en fait
différentes déclinaisons locales
déclinaisons locales que au début du 20e
siècle et bien on va tenter d'unifier
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire on va dire il y
a une seule langue et tous les apports
du latin du français on va les enlever
et on va les chercher des mots du
Gallois pour recréer en grande partie
une langue et encore une fois ce n'est
que l'ouest de la Bretagne à l'est donc
dans la ville de Vitré on parlait le
galop c'est une langue Dole assez proche
du coup de l'ensemble des longues dogs
donc le français et cette langue Dole
elle va être jugée les nationalistes
bretons comme étant pas très
intéressante parce que justement trop
proche du latin trop proche du français
quelque chose qui permet pas d'affirmer
la singularité de la collectivité du
coup qu'est-ce qu'on va faire on va dire
bah voilà cette ville elle a peut-être
jamais parlé bretons elle n'a jamais
parlé bretons depuis le Moyen-âge mais
on va sous-titrer les panneaux en breton
et on va créer des écoles en breton le
galop on va le mettre pour faire plaisir
mais en réalité il est 25 fois moins
financé par la Région Bretagne et de
l'autre côté dans le pack d'avenir pour
la Bretagne signé par Edouard Philippe
et René et Loïc schizney Girard et ben
il figure pas exactement et donc
aujourd'hui on dit sauver des cultures
et tant mieux il faut les sauver mais on
les sauve pas à Vitré cette culture
qu'on est en train de justement mettre
en avant c'est pas la culture locale
c'est une culture idéologisée
reconstruite à des saints d'antagonisme
national bien souvent parce que derrière
il y a d'autres choses qui vont il y a
certains langues mais il y a également
une histoire une reconstruction
historique et cette reconstruction
historique elle a été forgée par des
militants pour des militants et
aujourd'hui en effet elle va permettre
de promouvoir un esprit militant très
très en réalité
régionaliste dans un sens ethno
régionaliste et séparatiste c'est ce que
j'évoque dans le livre et ça c'est
dangereux donc il faut bien différencier
d'un côté forcément plus loin et pas on
peut pas défendre sa langue régionale
tout en se sentant attaché à la France
et à la langue française si vous
regardez ce qui se passe à Vitré qu'elle
aurait été la bonne attitude mais de
dire voilà ici on a toujours parlé
galops une variante du galop et bien on
transmet cette langue on transmet les
vraies cultures qui ont été les cultures
locales à l'endroit où elles ont vécu ce
qui permet en fait une forme
d'intercommunalité
entre les générations parce que là les
gamins qui vont apprendre le breton à
Vitré ou à Rennes ils vont pas
communiquer avec leurs grands-parents
puisque par définition leurs
grands-parents soient ils vivent en base
Bretagne mais la plupart du temps s'ils
viennent de Rennes bah ils parlait pas
breton et donc ils vont communiquer
entre militants et là on a un phénomène
qui est un phénomène qui n'a rien de
culturel et qui essentiellement
politique et qui détourne l'argent qui
devrait aller justement vers le
sauvetage des cultures locales vers
quelque chose qui est tout autre et qui
est un phénomène politique
moi je connais j'adore la Bretagne mais
je la connais pas suffisamment pour pour
décortiquer les mécanismes mais c'est en
tout cas pas du tout ce que je ressens
aujourd'hui en Alsace pour moi faire
gagner les territoires c'est faire
gagner faire gagner la France
aujourd'hui on a en Alsace on a le on a
l'Alsacienne on a aussi le Belge qui que
nous portons de nous partons également
bien évidemment qui est sur des
territoires plus plus réduits donc
forcément moins développé transmettre
aux jeunes générations ce patrimoine
linguistique ça nous semble ça nous
semble important aujourd'hui si on veut
revivifier la démocratie redonner envie
aux gens de s'impliquer parce
qu'aujourd'hui on voit bien que face à
tous les enjeux de la démocratie on a
besoin que les gens s'impliquent pour
que les gens
s'impliquent il faut qu'ils aient ce
sentiment d'appartenance faut qu'ils
aient envie de ce et je pense que à
travers notre culture on a un socle
commun qui donne envie aux gens de
s'impliquer moi je vois là on a
développé la marque Alsace on est le
territoire ou les
habitants consomme le plus les biens de
leur territoire on est à 8 % je crois
que la Bretagne est à 5 la moyenne est à
deux
ben on est fier de les gens sont fiers
de la marque de plus en plus
d'entreprises veulent avoir la marque et
c'est c'est un outil de lien un outil de
dynamique sur le territoire parce que
dans ce que vous dites ça veut dire que
les grandes régions mais pas que
peut-être la déconnexion qui est
ressentie par les Français envers leurs
élus ça renforce le sentiment
régionaliste
clairement aujourd'hui
on voit quand même le grand test nous à
nier les identités de territoire à coups
de millions de de communication sur on
voulait grand-testiser les choses moi
j'étais 80 jours à la rencontre des
habitants je leur demandais est-ce que
vous sentez grand Estienne ou grand
espoir il souriait les gens et le fait
qu'on ait voulue nier cet identité forte
en supprimant la région Alsace ça a
encore renforcé
cette volonté d'une retour à une
organisation institutionnelle qui a du
sens parce que aujourd'hui c'est ça
l'enjeu comment rebâtine une action
publique a du sens et bien je pense que
la bonne la bonne échelle territoriale
c'est déterminant est-ce que ces grandes
régions renforcer le régionalisme est-ce
qu'il y a eu dans certaines anciennes
régions le sentiment que leur identité
était niait évidemment c'est à dire que
alors c'est évidemment particulièrement
vrai pour l'Alsace mais si vous regardez
les Laurent les Lorrains ou les
champignons des noix c'est la même chose
exactement et je peux vous dire que
l'Auvergnat que je suis naguère aimée
d'être fusionné avec le Ronald et que la
capitale naturelle de cette nouvelle
grande région devrait être
Clermont-Ferrand donc évidemment on a
tous extrêmement mal vécu lorsque nous
avons été fusionnés ce qui était une
forme de négation d'identité même quand
les identités sont relativement récentes
parce que les les entites
administratives malgré tout à terme
charrie une forme d'identité mais je
pense que là-dessus on peut être
d'accord la suppression de la région
Alsace a été une absurdité et qui plus
est à stimuler le sentiment identitaire
mais la création de collectivités
là-dessus plutôt que le retour au statut
quantité et à mon avis un danger ensuite
vous évoquez la question de la
démocratie mais cette collectivité à
statue particulière elle a quand même
été rejetée en 2013 et cette
collectivité vous parliez de la
consultation que vous avez faite mais
cette consultation c'est le nombre de
voix qui a pas été voir il y a pas eu de
problème n'a pas été pas tout à fait la
même qui montre que ça n'intéressait pas
forcément les Alsaciens au point de la
mobilise aussi parce que ce qui était
proposé un organisation c'était quand
même une usine à gaz et aujourd'hui on
est dans quelque chose de très simple
nous on a organisé le l'Alsace en
territoire donc on a redonné le pouvoir
décisionnel aux élus en proximité ce qui
a changé complètement la donne et puis
le fait qu'on qu'on à l'époque on
parlait pas du grand test parce que
sinon le vote aurait été bien évidemment
complètement complètement modifié et
puis je vais juste revenir sur les
marques parce que aujourd'hui avec en
faisant une région Grand Est on a enlevé
la marque champagne oh la marche
champagne c'est quand même beaucoup plus
important que la marque que la marque
grand est oui de mots alors sur les sur
la démocratie tout de même c'est-à-dire
que moi je suis d'accord sur le fait
qu'en effet le grand test a changé la
donne mais fondamentalement l'idée que
on remet en cause le résultat des
référendum a été souvent le cas prenez
l'accord en 2003 référendum les corps
disent non on arrive à une collectivité
test du particulier
idem pour le grand
idem pour le pour l'Alsace donc là il y
a malgré tout un enjeu démocratique qui
me semble assez problématique sur les
marques je suis d'accord avec vous mais
attention c'est à dire que souvent la
marque Alsace la masse la marque
Bretagne etc véhicules également une
conception de l'identité qui souvent est
très très caricatural et favorise cette
diffusion d'un logiciel qui est parfois
un logiciel assez problématique donc oui
pour la promotion des territoires
attention tout de même à ce qu'on en
fait moi j'envoie une image de qualité
pour la France
on va voir alors il y a des
collectivités qui ont déjà un statut
particulier on en a parlé mais Alex il y
a des territoires qui tentent de faire
évoluer leur statut mais oui avec des
projets de fusion ou de dissociation à
direction d'abord les départements
savoyards avec et bien la question de la
fusion des deux départements de
Haute-Savoie et de la Savoie qui revient
souvent dans les débats et en 2019 au
moment de la création de la collectivité
européenne d'Alsace et bien le
département de la Savoie a proposé à la
Haute-Savoie de fusionner pour former un
grand département savoyard aux
compétences élargies mais pour l'instant
la Haute-Savoie a refusé à reporter le
débat aux prochaines années on va aller
maintenant au Pays Basque où il existe
depuis longtemps un mouvement pour la
création d'un département basse alors
qu'aujourd'hui et bien le Pays Basque
forme avec le Béarn le département des
Pyrénées-Atlantiques ce département
basque a souvent été une revendication
des indépendantistes mais depuis la fin
de l'organisation terroriste ETA et bien
ce projet est de plus en plus partagé
au-delà des indépendants des
indépendants d'istes basques et en
attendant et bien une très grande
communauté d'agglomération du Pays
Basque s'est formé avec les 158 communes
basques cela fait 315 000 habitants une
grande communauté d'agglomérations mais
sans les compétences d'un département et
certaines collectivités veulent plus
d'autonomie il y avait plus d'autonomie
c'est le cas de la Bretagne puisqu'on
printemps 2022 et bien conseiller
régional de Bretagne a voté un vœu à
destination de l'État pour organiser
d'ici à 2024 d'abord une consultation
sur la réunification de la Bretagne
c'est à dire le retour de la
Loire-Atlantique dans la région Bretagne
donc une région à 5 départements et puis
aussi pour dessiner un modèle
d'autonomie de la Bretagne une autonomie
réglementaire et législative c'est ce
qui est écrit dans ce vœu du conseil
régional avec bien sûr des transferts
financiers de l'État et des nouvelles
relations budgétaires et puis enfin il y
a la Corse Emmanuel Macron durant la
dernière campagne présidentielle c'est
montré ouvert à un statut d'autonomie
pour la collectivité de Corse les
discussions ont commencé entre l'État et
les nationalistes qui dirigent la
collectivité de Corse le ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald de Darmanin était
d'ailleurs ce week-end en Corse et
maintenant il attend les propositions de
l'exécutif Corse sur ce projet
d'autonomie c'était la Une de
Corse-Matin hier Frédéric Berry la Corse
c'est un modèle à suivre pour l'Alsace
ah bien évidemment je regarde avec avec
attention avec une différence quand même
c'est que nous nous on est profondément
attaché à la France ce qui est pas
forcément le cas partout
en plusieurs fois qui se posent chez
nous il y a pas de courant sur ce sur
cette question tout le monde est et
particulièrement clair si vous voulez ce
qui est important et la Cour des comptes
le relevé par exemple sur le RSA on a
besoin d'aborder les politiques
publiques à 360 degrés si aujourd'hui on
peut s'attaquer les que les départements
peuvent s'occuper des méfières du RSA
mais peuvent pas s'occuper de la
formation ils ont pas le droit de
s'occuper de l'économie donc on peut pas
aborder la problématique dans son
ensemble et aujourd'hui il faut que les
collectivités puissent retrouver un
pouvoir d'agir et pour moi le pouvoir
d'agir c'est le droit les moyens et la
maîtrise des moyens financiers c'est ces
trois composantes là qui sont essentiels
et c'est pour cette raison que moi
j'appelle de mes des évolutions
législatives en la manière ce qui
permettrait de d'améliorer le la qualité
l'action publique et la conclusion
Benjamin le régionalisme ça va prendre
de l'ampleur dans le pays alors si on
prend tous nos voisins européens à
l'exception de l'Allemagne qu'un modèle
très symétrique encore une fois ça a
pris l'ampleur donc soit on considère
qu'on est un petit Isola une sorte de
petit village gaulois ou tout ce qui
atteint le monde ne nous atteint pas
soit on considère que ce qui a produit
des conséquences fâcheuses à l'étranger
en Espagne en Belgique en Italie en
Royaume-Uni va également nous arriver
parce qu'on prend exactement le même
chemin justement avec cette approche
différenciée
avec des velléités qui en fait parce que
j'entends tout à fait votre point de vue
de dire grosso modo on est très
républicain et je vous en fais
absolument pas à la fois le reproche et
je crois sincère profondément mais ce
que ce qu'on constate à l'étranger c'est
qu'au bout d'un moment à force d'appuyer
sur ce logiciel et de créer un effet de
comparaison entre région et bien les
républicains ceux qui sont attachés à
l'unité nationale finissent fragiliser
prenez pas le Jacobi encore il reprend
juste avant son départ du pouvoir
revendications des nations statut du
résident etc etc il finit dévorer comme
le labour partie a fini dévorer par le
SNP en Écosse donc on voit ce jeu
augmenter à la fois dans mimétisme entre
régions et dans cette surenchère entre
parties et là il y a un vrai vrai danger
c'est-à-dire que à terme on sait de
manière quasiment statistique parce
qu'on a des statistiques où ça mène
est-ce que ça peut faire sur les nations
corps aujourd'hui il faut voir que
Simeoni est embêté la jeunesse Corse qui
s'est rebeller l'année dernière je
rappelle d'ailleurs que quand le Conseil
régional de Bretagne vote son vœu ont
des moments où la collectivité de Corse
mais ce sera pas en berne en faveur
divan Colonna donc je trouve que c'est
tout de même d'un peu mauvais goût mais
lorsque Siméoni est dépassé par sa
jeunesse sa jeunesse elle a été formée
dans l'amphithéâtre à quoi Viva à
l'université de Corte c'est le nom d'un
plastiqueur du FLNC vous pouvez ensuite
difficilement considérer que vous pouvez
tenir une jeunesse qui a été formée
ainsi et en 20 secondes Frédéric Berry
sur les le risque cessationniste moi je
n'y crois pas les régions allemandes ont
beaucoup plus de pouvoir et beaucoup à
agir mais que que les régions en France
ça ne remet pas en cause le rattachement
à l'Allemagne symétrie justement et on
refera un débat merci Monsieur d'avoir
été avec nous on va regarder la presse
régionale reste avec nous
[Musique]
et Alex elle a une de la presse
régionale la visite de Joe Biden à Kef
ah oui le prix
[Musique]